[Music]
thank you
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is stuff forgot there's a camera
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
we have yet again the random show yes
Kev Kev rose rose Kevin Rose thank you
for having me Tim it's good to be here
it's good to be here in your home we're
in we're in a a home we have our
matching mini scooters we do we also
have a miniature kitchen set behind us
we were making pinto beans and home
style ice cream yeah you may or may not
be able to see that their favorite
topping for pinto beans and by then he
means his progeny I have a couple little
ones that hopefully will not be making
an appearance that have gone to bed but
we shall see we've already had a
princess on the run a little jailbreak
who came flying through so
given before recording actually while
recording you said this is the important
juice but that was off mic so I relayed
it into the mic what is this important
juice that we have before us so I mean
we've been doing these shows for a very
long time so we've always well not
always we've highlighted some of our
favorite drinks over the years and one
of the things that I comes into my
possession about once a year
is a limited edition run you know it's
expensive when it's in passive passive
sentence form comes into my possession
that's right it sounds very fancy it's
just a beer people so one of the things
that I like to do and we've talked about
this before at some point but unlike
wine the cool thing about beer is you
can buy the best beer in the world like
the number one ranked beer and it's
gonna cost you a hundred dollars yeah
that's not the case with wine obviously
so in terms of different styles of beer
obviously it's typically not ipas that
win the number one slot on that it's
it's some of the heavier stuff but on
the IPA front the second highest rank
IPA by Beer Advocate and I would argue
the harder to find version of of the
ipas because the number one ranked IPA
is called heady topper and it is in
production year round this particular
beer by Russian River Brewing is called
planning the younger now you may have
heard of Pliny the Elder which is
you typically find at Whole Foods and
things like that the younger is a
limited edition run that they do once a
year and just they used to have to go to
Russian River Brewing to actually
consume it and just recently probably
I'd say three or four years ago they
started putting it in bottles so this is
it in Bottle form I would argue that
this is probably the most sought after
IP in the world
it is 75 a bottle so it's not cheap it
is a 16 ounce bottle though so per ounce
no it's a it's one pint yeah one pint so
it's it's expensive juice but it is
quite good and I wanted to share it with
you thank you and I also wanted to tell
people out there how to find the rarest
beers in the world let's do it I may
have mentioned this at one crazy long
ago random show but there is a place
that I go to called
mybeercollectibles.com This is an ad I
have nothing to do with them every time
I just mention any Urology
exactly make sure you get my 20 but one
of the things that that this is what I'm
probably gonna get them arrested but one
of the things that is very difficult to
do is to sell alcohol online yeah and so
on the beer front if you say and this is
true if you were to drink this bottle
you can sell the bottle by itself or
let's just say five dollars or whatever
it may be because the bottle is just
collectible in its own right and so what
they claim is that everything you're
buying is a collectible
and so you're not actually buying the
beer and so it's a it's a peer-to-peer
Marketplace yeah and so they have people
that go and buy that I've been using
them for several years now they're gonna
have the best month of sales before they
get shut down it's gonna be really a
blaze of glory they've been okay they've
been okay and they always I always find
really good sellers on there and you see
on the side of this it says you know not
package for resale so you have to know
somebody to get this and yeah I love a
good IPA and I would say this is this is
up there this is pretty pretty good
stuff
so you know the wine world you know
probably something about the Beer World
you also know the high-end I'm not even
gonna call them watches God forbid
timepiece World sure very well
how much of
the degree of scarcity or not scarcity
how much of the
Fame that comes from being sought after
is derived from the quality of the
product versus the scarcity versus the
positioning if there is such a thing
marketing other factors yeah I've become
really interested in this question and
there's actually a spectacular episode I
haven't listened to yet on lvmh and the
building of that right from its very
meager Beginnings to its insane current
state and there's a book called How
luxury lost its luster so a lot of
alliteration which I read a long time
ago I do find the this the study of sort
of scarcity yes and high-end products
very interesting have you read the book
the luxury strategy
the luxury of strategies luxury strategy
the luxury strategy I was like the
luxurious strategy it seems like a
necessity no I haven't it's actually
another really good one it talks about
just brand positioning and just how to
set yourself up as a you know a really
sought out here yeah Premier brand and
some of the mistakes that Brands make
where they go down market and they
become a commoditized kind of like you
know Ross Dress for Less it's part of
the reason why the fashion industry goes
and destroys so many clothes like it's
not because they have leftover clothes
they could go and sell them you know
it's what happened to guests jeans or
any of these other brands where they
said hey we have this extra inventory
let's discount it let's do outlet stores
right let's do you know these these
discounting stores then they get
anchored in the mid Market exactly and
then they go back up right once you go
down you can't you can't regain that
well we are we and there's so many ways
different ways to differentiate right as
one example
we're in LA right now and I had never
been to arawan so for people who don't
know erwan is a very famous
very expensive it's not expensive this
is well water let me paint a picture I
went in and I went to their hot meal
cafeteria line and I got a couple of
boxes I mean it's two meals maybe two
and a half meals for me and I was like
oh I got a kombucha too and you know
maybe a water and I think that was about
it there wasn't much more to it and it
was 147 I wanted to go there just for
the spectacle because I mean there's a
dating scene there there's this dating
scene it's yeah the point I was gonna
make is I was having a conversation with
someone and I told them the story they
said wow that's insane
I imagine if you took the same inventory
you could sell it for 20 less and do
really well and I said you could but if
everyone lowered their prices they would
be dead
I think right because this part of the
Allure part of the story part of the
word of mouth is
how expensive it is yeah I mean it's
that but also everyone's we could get
into here I mean look they have other
stuff that is I'm sure of incredibly
high quality and I I respect that also
but the reason I hear about arowan in a
place like Austin or other places in the
country is
highly exclusive very expensive yeah and
I'm not saying that as a knock
right well I think it's it's what we've
seen well it was just talking about
grocery stores even though this isn't
that most that interesting of a topic
but like but this maps to a bunch of
other things oh for sure yeah but like I
think when when you see Whole Foods get
bought by Amazon and it becomes this
kind of mass skilled Enterprise although
it was you could argue beforehand yeah
when you go in there it's not the level
of quality it was a decade ago it's just
not like it's it's been it's been
degraded and like this is now that next
new level right and it's not I would say
that when you go into Air1 it doesn't
feel bougie though it doesn't feel like
crazy like just luxury for luxury's sake
it's just like is that what you mean by
bougie because that word it gets I've
heard bougie said more times than I can
count since I got to La about a week I
think it's just kind of like it the one
thing I've only been in La a few months
and the one thing that I love about it
actually is that it's to Choose Your Own
Adventure yeah so you can go is crazy
high-end as you want to whatever you
want to that whatever you define that or
you can find an awesome little dive bar
or the gray cocktail right and so I
actually like that and like for me I
tend to like float somewhere in the
middle like don't get me wrong I like a
nice awesome steak and a great killer
Steakhouse which they have a lot of
those out here yeah but at the same time
it's like it's it's different than
Portland like Portland we didn't have
the high end we had a lot of the middle
so it's like erwan is is very small it's
a very small group it's super small I
was actually expecting it to be much
larger yeah so I go there and I've been
there since
and it is high quality the food is high
quality
I think the name is also from getting
this right an anagram of nowhere for
people who may be wondering nothing
interesting the experience that I had
actually yesterday
brought a lot of this to top of mind for
me and my experience yesterday was going
to this place called The Magic Castle
for the second time you went I did and
for those who don't know about the Magic
Castle I'm not going to do it justice
but it is the mecca of magic in the
sense that people from all over the
world
the kids who become obsessed with magic
sleight of hand illusion Etc
the one place if they've heard of it
that everyone wants to go is the Magic
Castle
and anyone who's anyone more or less in
that world blows through the doors
probably once a year did you dress up
you have to dress yeah this is where I
was going you have to wear a suit in
time not just die suit and tie I did not
come here with a suit and tie nor did I
come here with dress shoes so a friend
of mine who's visiting
who also didn't have any of the fancy
clothes because the opportunity to go
came up very last minute Men's Warehouse
we went to Hollywood Suits on Hollywood
Boulevard no we couldn't rent so we
bought suits but here's the thing from
the moment we walked in
and I know these are these are like
quality problems right the fact that you
can buy a suit that you'd never intend
to wear again is kind of insane but I
knew that it would cost close to the
same to rent and that we didn't have
time to rent because literally we found
out that we had the opportunity to go to
this amazing show it's a very small show
with an incredible magician who I'll
mention here because the show is
absolutely spectacular and then I'll
rewind so I'm going to get his name
probably pronounced wrong but Simon
Coronel c-o-r-o-n-e-l
people if you don't know this name you
are going to know this name this guy put
on one of the best shows I've ever seen
young person or yeah he's young I mean I
don't know exactly how old he is maybe
he's my age so I'll call that young yeah
just the older I get the younger I think
my current age is but we went to
Hollywood Suits we had literally I want
to say 90 minutes and we walked in not
we didn't even have nightmares we had an
hour we walked in
we just said here are sizes wear your
suits went over grabbed whatever looked
reasonably good off the rag I hate that
at least the Itchy because I hate it
hold on so we get then it's like what
size is your neck shirt Boom the guy
like throws it on top because it's sort
of a rack and stack high volume spot
right and then it's like shoes belt this
then the other thing and we walked out
the door with everything for between 150
and 200 a suit that's insane it's
awesome yeah so then they can't do the
we can't they can't do the hemming there
so you have to like go down this alley
around the corner and you think you
might be murdered but no you find
somebody who's in this beautiful staple
room though I've done that before you
could staple it we didn't have Staples
so you know we're we have to like call
an Uber in 30 minutes to get to this
place
and we get everything done literally we
walk in the door and then 45 minutes
later we're in our suits and we go to
the Magic Castle and my friend and I
both have
I don't have a lot of Suits right but I
have one or two nice suits for weddings
and things like that they're not cheap
and they're fitted in this than the
other thing and both of us
looked at the suits and okay these are
not the best suits in the world but they
are surprisingly fitting and
surprisingly good and we I got a
compliment on my suit while I was there
and it raises questions yeah right when
it's like okay this was a hundred and
fifty two hundred dollars
so what it what differentiates and yes
they're better materials yes there's
better fitting but then you're waiting
like five months for alterations or
whatever when you get into the super
fancy class and you're like okay that's
not about
entirely quality that's about the story
of the weight that's about being able to
tell your friends the process you went
through to get the thing right which is
not to diminish its value it's just to
say it's really interesting that so much
such a high percentage of the total cost
could be placed on that
so I think about these things do you
think you're gonna get into
any other high-end stuff although I want
to back up to your comment that to get
the equivalent in terms of grade for
wine yeah would just be impossibly cost
prohibitive right it's you're gonna
you're just gonna have to pay out the
nose and take out a second mortgage so
affordable luxuries right in terms of
affordable luxuries anything else
that you enjoy that you sort of put in
the same class for me one would be
chocolate you can get
one some would consider yeah the best
chocolate in the world and if you're
willing to spend even 20 bucks what's
your go to 50. I like dick Taylor I used
to be all right I want to hear yours I
haven't been in this world for a long
time but about 10 years ago I really got
into it this is this is when I was
actually I guess a little bit earlier
maybe 11 12 years when I was working on
the four-hour Chef I got into this and
looked at it very seriously I coffee you
can really get incredible coffee if
you're willing to pay up just a little
bit yeah absolutely yeah the coffee is
one that I I do pay up for I order a
subscription which is their single
origin high-end coffee from a roaster
called Proud Mary and they're based in
Australia but they have a location in
Portland Oregon as well and so they have
a varietal of coffee called a geisha
coffee Alicia yeah have you ever had it
before no so it is just like the most
delicate awesome floral beautiful
elegant coffee you can consume whereas
when you make it properly and I do I do
the whole measuring myself you know 32
grams of coffee 350 grams of water and
do it via pour over and when you do it
you don't need to add anything so no no
sugar no but no I was thinking the whole
the old days no different jobs
remember when we did remember coffee and
so on yeah exactly so um until I started
getting my cardiac markers measured
regularly oh my god dude I used to do
bulletproof coffees all the time where
I'd add MCT oil and butter and then just
I you basically drink that coffee in
about a half hour later disaster you
just [__]
it's just like the worst
why did we ever do that then I got my
numbers back from Matia and it's like
freaking like cholesterol is all jacked
up I do have an IV bag full of
triglycerides exactly what's Happening
Here
so yeah I would say you've nailed it I
think chocolate you know coffee is
another one coffee's something I you
know I do a cup every day so that's
great T's in the same camp you can get
really nice high-end tees that are
amazing for you know under fifty dollars
you know this is gonna be
Maybe funny coming right after talking
about health stuff and metrics but I
think when I get quite a bit older maybe
I'm like okay I'm on the tail end here
I think I might take up pipe smoking no
my dad used to smoke I love just the it
looks so relaxed but not inhaling and
the smell
of pipe tobacco yes is so incredible oh
dude I think I just want to be like a
cantankerous old guy in a rocking chair
on a porch smoking my pipe it's in my
book I used to go in of course I didn't
I don't know I mean maybe I wouldn't
inhale I guess you're supposed to just
bring it to your mouth and then like
puff away at it I don't know I don't
smoke pipes I think most people would
inhale but like they used to have these
old tobacco shops you could go into
where they sell raw tobacco and I used
to go in with my dad and that's a good
childhood memory because the smell is so
amazing it's incredible yeah it's really
really phenomenal so what else would fit
that and actually people should also
just ping us on Twitter and let us know
if if we're missing a category because I
enjoy thinking about affordable luxuries
that most people could
bring into their lives so they can carve
out a small
a small piece of time a small amount of
cash to really feel like they're
treating themselves to something that is
amazing right and they're just certain
categories where that's not possible
because of how much demand there is and
therefore how high the prices can
escalate there's a bunch of stuff I mean
for me there's little tiny micro
upgrades that you do
around your household when you think
about this stuff and there's
so I was I lived near a convenience
store and I had run out of of body soap
right and I went across the street and I
bought some dove like body soap and it
was like seed or something I'm like oh
that sounds okay whatever and I got
there by the time I got home I flipped
over the back of the label and it was a
bunch of artificial stuff in there like
it wasn't all as pure as the outside had
said it was in the front and I put it on
and it was like a perfume bomb it was
like so nasty and I was like why did I
do this and you go out and yes you spend
25 30 more and you get something from
Aesop or a similar brand and it's just
amazing and you just like speaking of
those little luxuries and I know that's
like probably about my little
lamborghined luxuries but I don't know I
like little things like that like little
tiny micro upgrades around the house you
know yeah I have I have a very simple
role when it comes to
soap and shampoo dating life though you
need to have upgraded [__] well let me
pause I'll come we can come back to that
if we want to
I know you want to
see where it goes
but I actually get complimented on my
skin a lot like people are like what do
you use for this and that yeah it's
beautiful yeah it's no it's luscious
it's great it's luscious it's very
Supple Supple moist
okay
and all I use I have four years only
used Dr Bronner's baby so basically
unscented baby soap yeah I'm getting a
thumbs up from your wife that stuff is
so simple
I never feel like I have dry skin I'm
bald so it makes it easy right it's kind
of one one tool for all things and
there you have it's not actually a
luxury but I'm just saying it's great do
I use that too actually it's it's great
stuff and you can buy them like gigantic
sizes so they last long time yeah so
that's my my comment on personal hygiene
and soap so dating life
you know we don't have to get into that
well let's see how many questions no I
was just curious like you know we
haven't talked about this in great
detail but I'm curious like how do you
do you change your house like you're
talking about the upgrades like you have
to like create a cozy change my house
well first of all I'm you know I'm
paranoid and crazy about Safety and
Security stuff so generally I mean first
meetings are always out somewhere public
and
for anyone who is currently in The Fray
of dating apps they know that it is by
and large just terrible it's so bad
and yeah I've found it interesting what
I would say is like if you're in a
relationship and you're like wow this is
hard this is this this is that and you
know it would just be so much easier if
I were single and I'd be having all the
fun in the world and it's like you're
just trading a different set of problems
so now that's not to complain about it
but I don't think this subject's gonna
go anywhere we can cut this no we don't
we don't we don't have to I'm just
curious but have you changed anything in
terms of like your workout regimens or
anything like that to get back into
fighting shape
well yes I mean I have been training I
mean my training is pretty consistent I
would say that one of the bigger
challenges about dating is that I do not
recover actually this ties into
something I don't recover from alcohol
nearly as well as I used to and the fact
of the matter is generally if you're
going out
people are going to want to have a drink
or it's just going to be social to have
a drink or two nothing crazy I have no
interest in that but even two glasses of
wine
I can't completely obliterate my sleep
and so the jury is out on what I'm gonna
bring up but there is
this product which I think you have
tried now I have I have not tried it
this was this was introduced to me by a
friend who swears by it and said he was
about to stop drinking which might have
been a good thing but he didn't because
he started using this product called
zebiotics
and zebiotics is
pre-alcohol probiotic drink
and there are these I keep hiccuping
like the stork from this last Saturday
morning cartoons after my like five sips
all right so 12 bottles of this and the
the basic selling point is that you are
consuming a Prebiotic and
I'm going to bring up the exact
Prebiotic because I would love to get
some scientific input from people who
can assess this or who have tried it
here is the the selling point in the
pamphlet so the world's first
genetically engineered probiotic
I mean first world's first is always a
strong a strong statement so I'd be
curious to to hear if anybody can verify
but built by PhD microbiologists
ebiotics is the only product that
actively breaks down acetyl aldehyde no
I added an a I knew I was going to do it
Daria
acetaldehyde I'm just saying it really
quickly acetaldehyde acetology
in any case
means when you drink booze it is
intended to help you metabolize or
neutralize at least some of the things
that will cause you to feel terrible so
this is back to the pamphlet we started
with a natural probiotic which humans
have been eating for centuries then we
altered its DNA to produce an enzyme
that breaks down the aforementioned word
that I shall not repeat this enzyme is
just like the one your liver uses but
our Prebiotic is designed to deliver it
to your gut a place where your liver can
access and where you need it most so
that last paragraph is where I'd love to
have people help me understand if
there's any credible signs to back this
up I went on PubMed I looked at some of
the studies related to the actual
strain of probiotic which is either
bacillus sutilis or subtilis and that is
spelled
b-a-c-i-l-l-u-s space
s-u-b-t-i-l-l-i-s zb183 the reason I
mention that is when I looked it up the
study seemed to show that it could
mitigate some
liver damage with excessive alcohol
consumption and so on but I didn't see
much on the gut most of the studies seem
to be in different strains of animals
and insects like silkworms of all things
I think were included
so who knows how that transfers so we'd
love to know what people think what does
your buddy say is it like preventing
Hangouts you said that this has
completely changed his life from the
perspective he went away like is he
waking up just he wakes up without the
type of hangover and costs that have
come with drinking prior now it's like
credit cards he hasn't charged as much
so other people might bring up something
like activated charcoal I would be
curious to hear if you found anything
helpful you have more mileage than I do
with drinking booze
I love this episode you're like hey you
like fancy rich [__] like tell me some
of the stuff as commoners can use but
first gets started dude do you do more
race [__] than I do so what what oh no
you're gonna go yeah
you'd lose that one
[Laughter]
all right so yeah you like to drink a
lot tell me more Kevin you alcoholic
you have a broader spectrum of expertise
as well thank you when it comes to oh
well then you put it that way yeah when
it comes to training yeah in the in the
dark arts alcohol consumption so Tim
thank you for mentioning that I did get
my PhD
now I would say that I did try this at a
at a party about four or five months ago
and I think you know you had made a joke
before the show started where like if
you're like is something about car
accidents and a helmet and like it's
like if you're gonna drive fast enough
oh no what I said was like there's a
point at which it doesn't really help
right okay when you're like Band-Aids
are great if you cut your finger like
you want Band-Aids right but if you just
like chop your fingers yes so that
that's been my problems every time I was
trying one of these I've chopped my arm
off like I was at a party where where it
was like everyone was passing them out
and I'm like oh like the hangover cure
like I'm in and then I have like five
drinks you know and it was it was our
big annual nft party not this year but
last year and it ended up being a lot of
drinks and so I woke up a little
hungover so anyway
it didn't work for me not a big product
no it could be great Dory if you you've
tried it have you had any success no
success there all right so I'd be
curious to hear what people think and
this is really broadly to lob a question
into the audience which is what have you
found helpful for hangovers and you can
just hit us on Twitter with hashtag
hangover no what's interesting I'm sure
they're gonna be a bunch of
sanctimonious people who are like I
don't drink that's what I do but
yeah hashtag old Liberty you guys can
not reply because we don't we don't need
those I've cut back a lot on booze but
occasionally there's a place for it and
by the way all you folks are like I'm
enlightened I don't drink anymore I just
use ketamine five times a week
you guys are going to have a rude
awakening in a handful of year did you
hear that they've they're finding
fentanyl mixed in with ketamine now of
course they are yeah fentanyl is mixed
in with everything and by the way folks
two milligrams overdose you're dead yeah
if you get stuff mixed don't mess around
yet another reason not to play around
with miscellaneous powders yeah what's
up next Doctor Kevin all right so I want
to talk a little bit about my obsession
with AI yeah let's do it because it's
changed a lot so let me just put it to
you this way
you know how I always track new [__]
like yes I pride myself in always being
someone to want to play with whatever is
kind of halfway working slash breaking
if it means that you know five years
from now I was able to spot something
early on and and you know hopefully
identify a trend before it really took
off so I would say that
gbt when it came out the chat gbt the
first few versions were just were just
fun for me it was kind of like oh I'm
having a conversation with AI wow it's
it's actually producing a real result
when I'm like typing to it it can help
me rephrase or rewrite a paragraph or
you know it can summarize some bullet
points like there's it was doing a lot
of little small meaningless more or less
tasks but quite well and then 4.0 came
out yeah so when 4.0 came out my
consumption of and usage of chat GPT
went from about you know let's call it
30 minutes a week to probably about five
hours a week now no kidding so I use it
a lot what are you using it for now I'm
using it to code so it can it can code
for me now so you know my background
here like I studied computer science but
I dropped out and part of the reason I I
don't know how much I've mentioned this
publicly but part of the reason I
dropped out was that
I could look and understand code a lot
faster than I can write it yeah and so
you know it's still to this day I can I
can read code just fine I mean this
granted sometimes there's some syntax I
would have to look up or figure out but
like more or less I'm there the issue
was that if I'm thinking through a
problem it would take me you know three
to four times as long as anyone else to
like figure out the same problem and it
just I just didn't have the brain for it
yeah GPT I can come in and as I start to
have little hiccups or I want to think
through a problem I can just ask it to
figure it out for me and it writes code
that is like 99 like ready to go give
you an example of Give an example let's
say you are your WordPress user right
that's what your blog's powered on and
you're like I want to write a new
WordPress plugin and I want it to do
this with my audience segment it like
this
do this only when someone is coming from
this country and make it appear like
this and you know you could change
anything you want you just describe it
in a couple paragraphs and say go it
literally will print out all the code
for you you copy and paste it and save
it as a script and you're good to go and
it works it's insane so what does that
mean for say five years from now well a
couple things practically speaking right
now my engineering team I had one of my
developers tell me hey I had this like
what they would call a a kind of
laborious kind of task of like just
something you don't want to code you're
like ah God I gotta Resort this data in
a certain way and like yeah this is
going to take me 45 minutes it was done
in five right and it's like using chat
GPS yes and so like all of those little
meaningless coding tasks they're just
gone right like that's it's already it's
done it's done yeah and so I've been
using it to create art and I can tell it
to go and write
p5.js scripts for me which is what art
blocks is based on for all the nfts so
art meaning you're using code to
generate generative art exactly and so I
can describe it visually and it comes
back with something that's amazing
that's cool I'll show you some examples
after the podcast I'd love to see it and
it's crazy addicting because you start
getting into it and you're like oh what
if you take it in this direction in this
direction so you're only limited you're
limited no longer by your skill but your
own internal creativity of your of your
brain and your ability to prompt well
yes yes but you can even help it right
I'll give an example this is about to
get super meta yeah exactly you can tell
it I'm having a hard time writing a
prompt how might I be more efficient and
it'll give you 10 ways to rewrite the
prompt see and it's so it just it's
helping itself it's so nuts yeah and so
once you realize that it's so much more
than just rewriting a paragraph where
you are helping put together an essay
but it can actually create real software
for you dude it's it's just
I realize now that what's going to
happen is that you know Mark Andreessen
was very famous very famous venture
capitalist maybe a decade ago of saying
software is eating the world right and
so it was this idea that we had all of
these old systems that were largely you
know pen and paper based or weren't
connected or weren't efficient and
software would come in and be connected
be put the data we've put in the cloud
and we would have you know this new type
of of in-cloud infrastructure right that
would power everything and be connected
like it never was before all that is is
is still continuing to happen but this
next generation is what I believe his AI
is going to eat the software so if
if software ate the world AI is going to
eat the software meaning that AI is
going to come in and reimagine every
single tool that we use so every single
productivity tool that we use it will be
a part of almost every application that
we use in in really meaningful ways like
I've seen it it sort data and create you
know so I don't know about you but when
I use Excel the hardest thing for me to
always wrap my head around and figure
out where pivot tables do you ever get
good at pivot tables no I never got good
at Excel period oh my God pivot tables
were one of those things where it was
just like it was it was a they're a
nightmare to I use notebooks and then I
lose my notebooks so anyway you don't
have to learn it any longer you just
tell it what you want how you want the
data slice and dice and it just like it
not not when I what I don't mean is the
output from chat gbt but I mean it will
be working in Excel or in Google Sheets
and just automatically rewrite the
tables for you that's why and so it's
you're just going to give it a little
prompt and that's it and I'm telling you
this this is coming a lot faster than I
had thought so two years ago it was very
linear to me I was like ah month over
month like oh yeah Chad gbt3 is out now
now 3.5 and I see a little bit of an
upgrade when four hit oh my God like it
seems like vertical it's gone vertical
it's exponential now and so dude the
next couple years are going to be insane
just insane yeah I think the next 12
months are going to be yeah you're
probably right I'm being conservative
yeah full cuckoo bananas I mean I've
been not to the extent that you have
probably been experimenting here and
there having my team experiment also to
see if people who are non-technical I'm
non-technical but I can figure out quite
a few things people who really have
maybe even an allergy to a lot of tech
tools like what they can do
just to try to peek around that corner
oh like okay what is this going to look
like when there's more mass adoption and
I ran an art competition which was an AI
art competition a while back
and
was absolutely this is for the punch of
[__] this is for the punch of [__]
the the punched the [__] is this they
say yeah translated in so many languages
now oh yeah no it's a massive Global
Japanese by the way
yeah so yeah
yes that was for the [__] punch nft
which raised 2 million bucks something
like that made 1.7 to 2 million bucks
for the foundation which is great all
that's been deployed and that's all
fantastic for scientific research but
the the point I was going to make the
art competition following that where fan
art was being generated using AI people
could also use Photoshop and other tools
to fine-tune or to manipulate anything
that came out of say a mid-journey or
dolly or something like that the results
absolutely blew my mind and I'm going to
be you heard it here first folks so I'm
going to be running some more
competitions which will have different
formats because a prerequisite or a
condition of valid submission for the
competition was you had to capture your
entire process well enough that somebody
could stand a good chance of replicating
a result
and by capturing that now we have let's
just say top 10 finalists you have 10
extremely good tutorials for people who
want to step into the ring and play with
it themselves so you've heard of stable
diffusion right I have yeah okay so
stable diffusion is one like mid-journey
it's one like you know any of these like
Dolly they can create imagery out of
prompts right
they so stable diffusion went open
source yep which was a big like of a
Maverick move yeah yeah but it was like
oh [__] because like they released it
once you release it open source yeah
everybody's got it and they're running
with it in different directions right
so
a buddy of mine gave me a Discord to go
into and he's like you gotta check this
[__] out this is crazy right and
it's called unstable diffusion okay and
so they basically took all the guard
rails off of stable diffusion yeah you
know all the protections and [__] oh my
God what kind of stuff do you see dude
what do you think you see
I don't know deep deep fake Taylor Swift
porn imagine anything no no anything you
can imagine in its ultra realistic like
state where you're you're almost like
you look at you're like is that an image
like it's like you don't even know like
it's tricked you already
but it's like the most elegant it's like
it's just say it no it's just like it's
it's like porn done and it's like finest
like a very tasteful AI important no no
but like you can do whatever you want
yeah so like there's all these different
channels and so you can go into some
channels and see like aliens with like
six breasts and like weird [__] like
where you're like that looks real not
like like what was it the movie a
Terminator Arnold Schwarzenegger was in
with the three breasted woman you know
what I'm talking about totally totally
cool yeah not that like this looks a
real like it it's disturbingly real
stuff right teenage boys are screwed
they're not they're screwed they're not
gonna get anything done in the next time
no but they're screwed in terms of
relationships dude yeah I'm telling you
this is what worries me so
remember the movie her right yeah I do
so rape movie one of the things about
her for people that haven't watched it
you got to go and watch this because
it's going to be going to become a
reality this man that has a relationship
with his phone and the phone has a very
serious like you know AI on it yeah
phone or laptop when he's at work right
there's this ubiquitous AI companion
just following him around right and one
of the things about open AI that you can
do now is you can save and train model
data to be persistent so I can go in
right now sorry for toaster licking the
bowl in the background
ringing the Tibetan meditation bowl with
US
dollar all right so what you can do is
you can go in and you can say here are
the properties of who I want you to be
and people are doing this there's this
website that has all these AI hacks
prompt hacks they call it and you can go
in and say you are this personality type
you're a little bit [__] or sassy like
blah blah and you can save this
and it will respond to you and learn
from you and you can have what appears
to be a human conversation with your
perfect like polar opposite or whatever
you're looking for in life dude I'm
telling you we're three years out from
that being conversation base have you
heard of replica yes of course I look at
that I almost invested in that company
years ago all right all right so you
should explain replica because they
claim to have 10 million registered
users yeah yeah so this was a company
that was Raising Capital quite a while
ago and I I saw them but it was before
the AI thing really took off yeah
but yeah I mean this is this is it like
this is this idea and I worry because
like you know you think of kind of
Africa as her just so you guys know I
mean there's more to it but yeah that's
basically it but imagine imagine you've
seen this you would know this better
than I would but in Japan there's been
this the decrease in in dating and I've
heard about there's like the shame of
like whether or not you have a high
quality job enough and like there's like
this disconnect between the male and
female population do you know what I'm
talking about there was a report that
came out on how dating was in the
decline well dating and fertility
fertility yes reproduction in general is
is on the decline and they're they're in
a very problematic situation from birth
rate like replacement rates they're in a
really sticky terrible situation okay so
now I think China could be in in like 20
30 years 20 20 years probably well I
think we were all going to be there
because population implosion you might
just have a partner online like a AI
yeah like we might just have ai Partners
you know well I was talking to
I was talking to someone about this
because as you mentioned right I'm I'm
single now and they said oh you should
hop on replica just like check it out
and I was like I don't actually want to
scare you it well it scared me in the
sense that I was like okay there are
times when I'm really lonely yeah and
humans are messy humans are difficult
and if you get close to someone it's
great for a while you have the honeymoon
phase and things are great and puppy
love and like everything you do is so
funny and then things change right and
it gets a little more complex but if you
had an AI companion who especially if it
were compelling voice which is going to
happen immediately I mean two years it's
already like I've seen
I've seen AI I can't remember the
company names but that have been trained
on voice data yes to mimic and I
actually know podcasts are being
produced right now this year using AI
we're not even here AI to read
Scripts
that are sort of pieced together from
celebrity sample data yes and listeners
have no idea yeah they have no idea like
these podcasts are
not quote unquote real because it's not
what you think it is and
we are so close to there being the
equivalent of like the Scarlett
Johansson her right like sexy smoky
voice like sassy funny getting there
gives you a little [__] from time to
time but doesn't ask you to pick up your
socks yeah right right that kind of
thing dark is looking at me yeah I'm
just I'm kidding me I didn't want to dig
into replica because I was like you know
there's a chance yeah that it's better
than I think it's going to be yes and
then I start playing the game because
I'm like oh I'm just testing the service
and then I start getting my human needs
met by this Ai and it happened and it
takes the pressure off of which maybe
sometimes could be a good thing but
takes the pressure off of human
interaction dude I think this this is my
point this is why I wanted to bring this
up I think this is going to happen the
question is if I Children of Men here
actually I have a question for Daria
like if I start talking to someone on AI
that is a female AI person is that
cheating
it is yes what that doesn't no no I'm
just repeating what she said that
doesn't that doesn't surprise me I've
thought about this a lot too I'm like
cheating if I talk to Ai and well I mean
especially if it's like sexting and this
then the other thing why is that
cheating
it's an AI what did she say she said
well you don't talk to me
well stop bitching about my
yeah I think that this will become an
absolute issue right it's going to be a
huge issue this is one of the things
that it really truly keeps me up being
like I either need to invest in this
company or avoid it or a combination of
thereof yeah and invest in it so that
you can have your bug out bag and your
your bunker yeah
it's just everything prepared for the
apocalypse okay speaking of the
Apocalypse do you mind if we switched
yeah let's do it let's do it that was a
fun one biology bet that was a fun one
I'm glad you brought that up so I I'm a
spectator mostly at this point maybe
I'll I'll just serve as a stand-in for
the audience for those who are not
deeply intimate with crypto or this
world but what what bet so Balaji
srinivasan what bet did he make roughly
we don't have to get all the dates right
or anything like that and what do you
think of it yeah so basically for people
that don't know
this is an individual biology is like
really well known former CTO of coinbase
yes and also it just insanely well known
for
nailing a lot of the covid predictions
yeah like he came out and said you know
things like really intimate details like
you know masks will be a fashion
statement like really early on right
like this is like where if you read the
stuff and we all have a historically
going back you'd be like wow that like
that Bravo like really prescient stuff
right so
you know when he talks about the future
a lot of people pay attention yep and so
one of the things that happened with the
the collapse of the of a lot of regional
banks with svb and then first Republican
others is he said you know this is this
is not an isolated event there's going
to be a triggering that's going to lead
to hyperinflation the devaluing of the
dollar and in the next 90 days Bitcoin
is going to be worth one million dollars
a coin and I'm willing to stake and bet
a million dollars that that is the case
so somebody else had challenged I think
he responded to someone who said I'll
put a million dollars online he's like
I'll take that bet okay I think June
17th or something yes yes so you're more
yeah than I am but that was essentially
it so that led me to pay attention I was
like okay well a lot of people pay
attention right let's let's dive into
this and figure out what's going on with
Bitcoin and honestly what it it caused
me to do personally is I hadn't paid
attention to Bitcoin in a long time yeah
I've been in the world of ethereum with
nfts and everything else and there's is
something like nice about how scalable
and green ethereum is that now that's
moved to proof of stake and there's just
a lot more activity there day to day
than there is say Bitcoin right but I
started digging into Bitcoin
and one of the things I realize is that
in a world where the Press Cycles are
always coming back to or oftentimes
they're hitting ethereum pretty hard and
that their nfts go up they go down they
go left they go right that's like a bad
look for ethereum in some cases people
get hacked it's a bad look like lose a
certain amount of money yeah I know that
quite well but I'm just saying that
there's these certain black eyes and
there's something about the Simplicity
of Bitcoin and the store of value that
is still attractive because it is it's
the OG cryptocurrency it's still trading
at over thirty thousand dollars as at
the time of this podcast and every year
that goes on it seems to be you know a
more legitimate asset recording on April
16th yeah but but every year that goes
on it seems to me what more legitimate
ass that is going to stay on the test of
time it's not going to zero right like
it's a digital currency it was the first
of its kind so you know I started
playing around with
some of the layer two that's built on
stop on top of that with a lightning
Network and notice that some of the pain
points have been smoothed down a little
bit and then I realized one thing that
that caught me where I was like you know
what you explain to people who don't
know what that is yes so Bitcoin is
notorious for being just a very
low transaction per second blockchain so
if you threw like say
you know the Visa scale at it like how
many times a Visa card gets swiped every
day it wouldn't even it would just it's
laughable it's like they can do you know
singular low double digit transactions
per second whereas Visa can do you know
40 000 Plus or whatever maybe these are
rough estimates but you get what I'm
saying it's along those orders of
magnitude so
Bitcoin had to figure out a solution
that would scale help it scale that
infrastructure so that more payments
Could Happen yep and so they created a
layer two that kind of sits on top of it
that still has final it resolves back to
the main coin so it has the security and
safety of Bitcoin it's much how ethereum
is scaling right now with some of the
layer two networks that sit on top of it
so their main one is called lightning
it's the lightning Network and so it
allows you to do ultra fast transactions
and it can scale up to they say I think
it's up to a million transactions a
second or something something crazy they
haven't tested it at those limits but
that's what the paper is written as
anyway so I tried a bunch of this stuff
out I kicked the tires on a few things
and then I realized that
Bitcoin unlike ethereum the nice thing
about it it has this you know finite
Supply that is slowly coming to an end
like over time right so every I think
it's four four and a half years they do
a happening event where they decrease
the total number of issued coins in half
they just chop they chop it right in
half as in terms of the number of coins
new coins issued
and they're about to do another cycle
here in a little over a year
so when this next happening event
happens there's even less currency
coming out of that faucet so you know
these happening events I went back and
looked historically and they're
typically the year before the happening
event in the year after The Happening
event you typically see a pretty how
many substantial things have there been
quite a few I mean so I it's like five
now or something like that
so you typically see and I don't get me
wrong like I'm not saying this is not
investment advice this is not always
going to hold true but obviously if
there's more demand and less Supply
meaning less Bitcoins being issued
you're going to see a change in price
that's just you know obvious obviously
we know these markets help them how they
play out so no one's talking about the
happening yet it typically people start
raising chatter around this time and so
when every single other time when I when
a happening events start to happen and
the chatter starts to spin up the price
has always gone up and I've watched this
happen time and time again so for me I
was like you know what classic
cryptocurrency I hate that it's not
green that kills me I'm happy that more
mining services are going green and
they're moving to cheaper energy sources
which are typically by
like thermodynamic and a bunch of the
nuclear energy in it but they try to win
they're exactly a ton in Texas yeah so
they're trying to move closer to these
energy sources they can get cheaper
power that said I still think there's
obviously a lot of of dirty energy
that's being wasted here on Bitcoin
mining it's a big bummer but you know
that is the one
part that just gives me a little bit of
pause that like kind of hurts my soul
but I I did you know
purchase a little position there because
I do like it especially in times where
we see the devaluing of the dollar we
see Russia and China buying more gold
and I'm just like I want a nice hedge
that's decoupled from the dollar that's
sitting out there that you know I'm not
saying it should be a big double-digit
percentage of your overall you know
asset allocation but for me personally I
I don't mind having a little that parked
instead on the side
so
maybe you could repeat for the audience
what you said to me this is a while back
but when we were talking about this we
were talking about
what might happen if the dollar is just
massively devalued or if we experience
hyper hyper hyperinflation yeah we're
like carting around dollar bills and uh
wheelbarrows to buy you know a KitKat at
the local 7-Eleven well you and I were
talking about this and we're like oh
this crazy bet happened this was
probably like what maybe a month ago or
something and we're like this crazy bad
happened it's a million dollars and if
Bitcoin goes to a million and I was like
wait a second like if Bitcoin goes to a
million dollars and there's
hyperinflation then a million dollars is
worth like and you said yeah like the
price of a sandwich or something like
that and I was like yeah so it doesn't
really matter like bitcoin's a hard one
because when you traditionally think
about currencies you always think of
them Peg to somebody else's GDP right so
you think of the the pound being pegged
to you know what's going on in the UK
and it's like what do you pay Bitcoin to
yeah well also like there's the question
of like what is its value in the absence
of a reliable Peg right exactly
yes I mean this is to be clear I'm sure
the Maxis are going to have a field day
with this one but
there are some people I respect and
admire among that crowd but they're also
a lot of very aggressive
sort of religious fundamentalists in
there which which I'd prefer not to
spend so much time with but the there
are a bunch of questions that I have
which I don't have great answers to but
they're just questions one would be what
you just described right it's like okay
well
if the dollar experiences this massive
hyperinflation what does how does one
establish the value of Bitcoin for the
exchange of services or Goods right
right
the second I think is for me what
happens in a place like Europe what
happens in a place like Japan what
happens in a place like fill in the
blank if the U.S collapses
right
so where is the sort of currency Safe
Haven right if there is one and then the
next question is
if if things were to get that bad
and it doesn't even need to be
if we assume for the moment that the
rise in bitcoin price to let's just say
biology is BET of a million is
predicated on a
on a similar increase in hyperinflation
for the dollar right right which would
just not be sustainable right the whole
country just blows to pieces
do you not have more pressing problems
than Bitcoin right like are you going to
be able to get on your United flight to
escape the us to fill in the blank
location
you're going to have such a series of
questions that are more fundamental
perhaps than
money that if you think that is a likely
outcome you should be in full blown
Advanced prepper mode right now right
well the the question I I guess I I
think I have is like are the rails in
place
for the Preppers to get into Bitcoin
because if something happens where we
see this massive or the bitcoiners to
get into prepping properly
but yeah but let's let's we can deal
with the first yeah so the first one I
would say is like you know
in this is two of us playing economists
on the TV on podcasts which is some
booze with some booze which is never
sound advice but yeah yeah this is not
economic advice but any Central Bankers
are listening right yeah exactly please
come on join us so the the one thing
that I I think is is interesting is when
you think about what is happening
worldwide right now with with China and
with Russia and we take a look at the
data what does the data tell us over the
last few months and what has been
reported is that China and Russia right
now are not buying Bitcoin but they're
buying a lot of gold and so that to me
doesn't signal as though we have an
emergent new world currency as much as
it does instability and a flight to
safety and so if there's instability in
a flight to safety and gold is still you
know the the kind of safe haven for that
which it appears to be that would
explain why I mean there's been since
November there's been a 40 run up on the
price of gold yeah and so you know I
don't know that Bitcoin is that safe
haven but there's one chart there's one
graphic that blew my mind and it made me
rethink everything and that is when the
day that svb came out and said we're
potentially insolvent and all the
regional Banks took a hit yep there was
a screenshot did you see the screenshot
do you know what I'm gonna talk about
there was a screenshot where someone
saved to their iPhone all the regional
Banks all the major Banks even as well
and it was a list of all of them in the
stocks app right you know how you can
list them like it just goes down the
screen it's like negative 20 negative 15
negative 30 like just going down the
street yeah that's like frb was like
negative 60 or something it was just
bloody all the way down and then there
was two at the top it was Bitcoin and
ethereum and they were both green like
heavy green and that was the first time
where I was like oh [__] because every
single time there has always been at
least and this is someone's
observational data like I'm just like
what from what I can recall
the market has been more or less tightly
coupled with Bitcoin and ethereum like
the Market's Down super tightly coupled
if the Market's down there down right
because it's a speculative asset and
when people start to feel their
pocketbooks hurting they pull out of
cryptocurrency this was the first time
where I was like oh [__] some people are
moving into cryptocurrency as the banks
start to collapse now In fairness that
is a subset of stocks especially if
you're looking at Regional Banks and not
the S P 500 right yeah I'm pretty sure
the SP was down that day too but I I
don't I imagine
let me ask you this and you know that
I'm pretty heavily vested in in these
things so I'm very deeply interested in
Bitcoin but just to just to act as a
stand-in let us assume that
and based on at least the homework that
I've done which you know your mileage
may vary but the the s p has been very
highly correlated to bitcoin and
ethereum for that matter yeah right and
it these are treated as risk on assets
yes and when things go down people sell
especially when they're most risky when
you can sell it whenever you want to
sell it and it's almost Market hours
yada yada what is different this time
around
because I do think there there are two
issues with the BET one is that and this
is this is this happens to everybody
right you develop a
it's not quite a sunk cost fallacy you
develop a confirmation bias right you
begin
to find reasons to support your book
yeah your existing positions and and
just one more thing and that is
I do think the biology bet can't be
viewed solely as a prediction because
people pay attention to him people
purchase or sell based also some people
do biologies predictions and so on and
it makes me think of this section in
liars poker by Michael Lewis it's the
book that made Michael Lewis famous it's
a great book it's about I think it's
mostly about
mostly about bond trading and there's
some like big swinging dick top dog
inside I think it was Solomon Brothers
and
he bought some position he was like the
Market's gone up 4X and he bought like
five hundred thousand dollars worth and
it started to go down and people were
laughing and he had lost a bet and
people were making fun of him and he's
like oh yeah and then he bought like
500 million dollars worth of it and the
market freaked out and went
skyrocketing because they're like oh my
God somebody knows something we don't
know
so he was able to move the market right
right he made a prediction but he also
moved the market and I think that
I don't think biology is bad always
can't move the market it's too big well
I'm not saying he can't move the market
but it was it became global news right
yes you don't think he can move the
market even if it affects larger
institutional players and so on now I'm
not saying that biology
single-handedly can move the market but
I think it's I don't think it's fair to
say that it has zero impact on the
buying and selling behaviors oh no doubt
I mean I think anyone can temporarily
move the market if Tim Ferriss tweets
out oh my God one of my best friends
insane researcher just found a hole in
Bitcoin we're all [__] you know I have
a right I have a strong feeling that
there would be some movement in prices
right like but you're saying it would
recalibrate yeah exactly exactly there's
just too much volume going through it
every single day like don't get me wrong
like if it's a hype cycle right yeah
like Kramer's gonna talk about it like
people are gonna it's gonna spread it's
gonna have its 48-hour window and then
there's gonna be a bump which we I think
we saw and then it'll just recalibrate
from there so but I thought it was
irresponsible to make that type of
public pronouncement I would be shocked
if it gets to A Million by midnight I
don't know that it's irresponsible I
just think it's like there are there are
people who not afford to take their
savings and put into Bitcoin who are
going to do it because of something like
that well the good news has gone up
since he said that so they're uh
regardless well yeah it's one thing to
get into a position yeah as you famously
know because you're like I'm buying this
and then you never tell me when you
[__] sell things
Jesus Christ all right man yeah yeah
good Lord all right so let's let's move
on from there
so
I have some fun stuff to talk about does
do it
I guarantee you you're gonna love this
next little segment all right I'm
excited okay yes
we talked about New Year's resolutions
before Oh God but I have one that I
didn't tell you about okay
I want to show you something here all
right you've seen this for the first
time you can go ahead and read this for
the audience here what does that say
it says ABC letter tracing practice
workbook for kids age is what ages three
plus okay and then when you open the
first page what does it say oh Kevin
Rose age 45 February 9th 2023. and then
what do you see from from here oh you're
letter tracing yes so I'm learning how
to write with my right hand amazing this
is incredible it's pretty it's pretty
shaky
your hands are a little shaky you can
see that I'm having some issues here
I please love stop laughing in the
background my wife is like dying
it's so good it's funny it's funny she
didn't know about this this is the first
she's hearing about by the way this is
great I have started to learn how to
write with my right hand yeah and I just
I see these cute bunnies and acorns it's
getting a little mushrooms and puppies
making it interesting so you know I'm
just now getting started I got a ways to
go but you know this is one of those
things where I was watching my kids do
it and I'm watching their brains kind of
activate as they're like learning how to
trace and how to and Zelda's really
actually her letters were flopped and
turned around at one point another
straight that's what I did you did the
same thing yeah yeah I still do it this
graphia my letters end up backwards and
ups and down and stuff when I write some
letters yeah and handwriting sometimes I
skip a letter and then I come back and
rewrite it I don't know what the [__]
that is but that's something I got I
don't know I get too much crazy and I
just like jump early onset Dimension
great thank you but but the thing here
is is you know there's no I have no
scientific reason other than to say I
realize that this is activating
somewhere in my brain something new yeah
and it's just like one of those things
where
I'm left-handed so I've always smudged
the [__] out of everything I did yeah
it's just like a streak of ink across
the page because my hand and I was like
you know what my kids are learning why
don't I learn at the same time and so
that's something I started that's
awesome anyway I thought I enjoyed it
yeah it's fun you just like actually my
hand gets really fatigued and so I have
to start you know so I set a timer for
10 minutes and then I just go to town
and like start doing my my numbers and
my letters and then it's like I got two
workbooks in my office that's amazing
yeah it's just I thought you would like
because I love them learner like yeah
you'd be into I'm totally into it and I
know what it's doing for me is like
helping my a certain part of my brain
Daria has neurosciences yeah Daria would
have more credibility discussing this in
any capacity there there is something
kind of similar that when did you start
this just the beginning have you tried
writing with your left hand I have
because I've broken so many things so
many times so I when I shattered my
right wrist one of several times I had
to do all my writing in school with my
left hand and for the first week it was
terrible I was also
just thrown into baptism by fire which
was like okay now you get to write for
like several hours a day with your
non-dominant hands yeah so are you good
are you can you oh I don't think I'm
good especially because left hand is I I
mean I say it's weird I'm sure
right-handed is equally weird for you
but just like the whole like hook yeah
the claw so I wanted to pull up the name
of an artist who got me back into
penciling and she was not aware of this
but she published a book that I ended up
grabbing which was unbeknownst to me a
guide to her tool kit and approach to
much of her artwork
I'm so tired folks it's not any booze
slept terribly last night maybe we'll
talk about my low back I have all sorts
of low back issues I had low back this
morning so this woman I might be
pronouncing her first name in correctly
but I'm gonna say Eliza Ivanova and her
account on Instagram is Eliza
e-l-e-e-z-a one of my favorite artists
out there she's spectacular can I see
some more stuff yeah yeah formerly at
Pixar
and her ability to draw animals and
portraits
is just spectacular and there's a
certain like surreal
oh I love this feel to it and she's you
see what she's using here I'm showing an
Instagram video she's using a smudging
stick instead of say cross hatching
which can be really rough on the wrists
and the hands to very quickly create
amazing pieces of Art and
she has a number of books I bought her
most recent book which gives sort of an
overview of her technique and approach
to artwork and so I have been like this
type of stuff for instance rather than
starting with sort of a stick figure or
a
not quite mannequin that's not the word
I'm looking maquette not maquette but
rather than starting with the bones of
someone starting with the the outline of
the figure then adding the shading then
adding the details and going back and
forth It's so don't you just wish you
had that skill set I mean you're really
good but like you're not that oh she's
better yeah she's obviously much better
on by the way yeah I do I can't see it
so this is a new thing all right you
want to hear a story you're gonna love
this yeah protecting your room
protecting my screen yeah but well this
is a privacy screen yeah and I went to a
restaurant here in LA
and
sit down at the bar because that's
what's what's available huge bar it's
like 75 feet wide by yourself yeah no I
just finished a workout oh she's texting
me up when you're doing [__] like this
I'd come join you for drink that's
horseshit you're always super busy we're
in the same neighborhood all right all
right I will text you next time yeah
yeah so I had done a workout I finished
and then I was just like hey looking for
a place to eat what can you guys
recommend ended up at this restaurant
and then I was sitting there ordered my
food having a great time beautiful venue
like flirting a little bit with the
waitress like that's not going to go
anywhere but it was fun like she was
just like Good Vibes yeah it was it was
just it felt good right and like what
was that this is a good example like it
wasn't it clearly wasn't gonna go
anywhere but it was just it was just fun
and then
somebody comes and sits right next to me
there's like 20 empty seats I had this
one I was pissing one time yeah movie
theater okay all right if there was 30
urinals and a dude walks all the way
down and stands right next to me yeah
all right yeah yeah thank you so is that
right next to me and ultimately ended up
being
a fan of mine and he was very cool but
the fact that he was sitting right next
to me meant I felt very self-conscious
looking at my phone I was like if I look
at anything on my phone or I try to text
someone or anything this is incredibly
visible to everyone around me and so I
ended up getting a privacy screen for my
iPhone which is fantastic I mean such a
simple solution also because Texas Works
quite well and there you have it so
that's that's my story that's the my
story about the Privacy yeah cool cool
story bro yeah Jesus Christ
do you have a name for the privacy
screens so these people can buy it if
they're like you know I do Tim Tims
Sims privacy screens.com it works quite
well I'm actually kind of shocked
because I can't see [__] from you and
I'm sitting like a foot from you yeah I
really can't see anything it's amazing
it's amazing it's really helpful so let
me let me try to find this and it's
gonna all right I'll start with the next
story right here there is a well hold on
there's a brand it starts with a B it's
not bellcom belt it's not polski
Belkin Belkin yeah yeah thank you Daria
so I think it's I think I initially was
looking for a Belkin because those are
well known and I ended up being unable
to get it quickly so I just have
something made in China that is a
similar design so there you have it but
the the key term is iPhone protector
slash privacy screen and if you search
for that you'll find something
all right
now that your privacy is covered
on to my next story which is Nintendo
enough about enough about you let's talk
about me so let me ask you a question
when do you think what Nintendo was
founded
uh I have maybe some unfair advantages
here I'm gonna say
1880. yes how did you know that was I
was that close yeah it's in the late
1800s yeah because
1839 no it was like later
1800s so the reason I know that this is
actually you probably don't even know
this so there is a Japanese card game
there's tiny little cards they're
they're like half the size of a business
card
and one of my favorite games I played
when I was an exchange student is called
hanafuda hanafuda has these beautiful
drawings and it's simply put it's a it's
a matching game in in a sense and
Nintendo became famous for first making
these card games oh crazy can you still
buy them when they're like collectible
yeah you can see that's so cool it's
super cool super Super Nintendo on them
Japanese yeah yeah absolutely is it
little Mario characters no Mario
characters but yeah that would be
amazing Nintendo I don't know what the
nin is 10 is heaven and then do is like
place of
so like shokudo is a cafeteria like the
I thought it was the place the it's a
homonym so dough is the same dough is
the same like Aikido like is the Waist
Away different character okay yeah no
kanji kanji different kanji Yeah a
different different character but
Nini is
yeah well anyway we can come back to
that but
all right speaking of Nintendo so
Nintendo
as you know my my firstborn is named
Zelda um
there's a new Legend of Zelda the tears
of the Kingdom opening May 12th
which is soon not as soon I am very
excited for this release and I started
playing the old original Zelda like the
very first one cool so you can plan on
the switch should they have emulators
now that you can get on the switch now
the switch has the traditional switch
controllers but Nintendo released the
original these are charging so they
slide off check this out this is the
original Nintendo controller that's cool
you can get so that's awesome yeah
exactly so it's this brings back so many
memories official from Nintendo not
because you could always find like the
Clone USB Nintendo controllers and with
the fakes and all that that has the same
feel like you push the button it's like
okay everything about it yeah and then
they charge when you slide them on the
side of the switch they charge so that's
brilliant USB it's so cool that's
brilliant isn't that awesome that's
super awesome they have their pass now
where you can get all the original
Nintendo games that's fun it's crazy I
was on the marketplace and and you know
my dad's passed away in one of the
things that I remember as a child is
there was the original Nintendo pinball
game and my dad used to watch me play
and he he actually had a little tiny TV
for me so I could like play next to him
as he's watching his shows or whatever
and I remember he never wanted to play
any games with me like he wasn't really
like he was an older dad and he didn't
really like get into Nintendo but when
pinball came up he's like okay let me
grab the controller and so he played
Nintendo with me so when I saw that I
was like oh my God like he gets I mean
yeah exactly Nostalgia I'll just teach a
word for for folks who may be interested
in Japanese they use it a lot more than
we say Nostalgia but they would say not
Takashi natsukashi
that's sort of got the same feel as
nostalgic but they they use it kind of
like saldaji and in Brazilian Portuguese
but it's uh roughly like ah like how
nice like Ah that's really nostalgic
that brings back the memories there was
a blog post that I saw where it was like
25 words that existed Japanese that
don't have
English meanings you know yeah and
they're so beautiful they capture these
like amazing just like moments in time
like there was this one that was like
the sunlight as it falls between
branches branches yes
like dappled sunlight coming through
tree branches and leaves oh good it's so
good it's so amazing like they have a
word for that that's so amazing yeah
super beautiful so so I was I was in
Tokyo yeah celebrating my 10-year
wedding anniversary congratulations
again yes
that was amazing and we had a ton of fun
Daria met me out there we did a moon
Birds Meetup so we had over a hundred
Japanese speaking Moon Birds collectors
out there which was challenging and
awesome at the same time and then Henry
my zen instructor here shookman here in
the United States introduced me to the
head of his lineage of Zen
who I got to go out and meet with and
sit down with and have a good karaoke
yeah exactly we're not drinking and just
the karaoke together all night long no
but we we had a little private Gathering
and sit down and did a a private delays
on you exercise the demons there was
there was he helped me with my practice
and game he speaks his English is quite
good and
it was it was very intimidating very
into that this is the that's it that's
actually goes in which is like a big
Ensemble that's right yeah three
Treasures like a big lineage of Zen and
I'm sitting here with this guy you know
and he's just like asking me very
pointed questions about my intention
what is your intention with my daughter
yeah more or less but it was like very
cutting questions dude like like what
Like a Surgeon just coming in and just
like I don't know if I should say the
things because it's this private
interview you know he gave me all the
[__] with not being able to come up with
the brand of privacy protector okay all
right no it's just
it's just like it asks me all these
amazing questions now I can't talk I'll
give you an example it's like he's like
it's more or less like
why are you here like where are you
you know how in Zen they have these
these phrase we've talked about these
cons before you've done interviews with
Henry and thank you for doing those like
yeah where it's like these moments where
of really good zen master can come in
and look at a student and know kind of
exactly the little nudge they need to
give them there's these like moments
where they they call it like there's
these stories in Zen World they grab
your coat and yank you in a certain
direction just to kind of get you to
like Snap like wake up like you know
this moment just boom they want you to
pop yeah and it was very much that like
why are you here what do you what do you
want from this like boom boom boom like
this rapid fire like I think the guy was
true when I walked back to my Airbnb in
Venice asking those questions
exactly and
less fentanyl driven but yeah so it was
amazing it was very special here this is
a masters have cut back on their fennel
a lot yeah this guy was operating in a
gym so what does that feel like for you
like what was why did you want to do it
first of all because I just you know
Henry had said such great things about
him that
you know and Henry is is he will never
say this publicly but I believe he is
one I'll say it for him no I will
because I think it's important like he
he's he's such a modest guy that like
Henry is one of I think it's like five
or so it's like fully sanctions and
Masters in this lineage and that's a big
deal when there's you know hundreds of
teachers in this in this realm so
you know this is his master his teacher
if you get a chance to take that meeting
you take it you know and so you know I
wouldn't you know like no I'm busy yeah
I'm going to try on some new shoes I'm
too busy going to try some fancy
Japanese coffee but
which I did which is amazing Cafe mamea
out there is fantastic but honestly
though the one thing that I I took away
from it for for people that that I will
share is that one of the things that he
asked me is he's like how how often do
you practice and how long do you
practice and I said you know I practice
25 minutes a day probably five days a
week and he goes what about the other
two days and I go well I got to start up
I got this I got that and he goes I
don't care and I'm paraphrasing here
because I don't care if you've practiced
five minutes a day he goes don't miss a
day don't break a day continue to do it
don't don't miss a day and
since then I have not missed a day
and I will say it's it's kind of amazing
because even if you can sit down for
five minutes it just keeps that
continuity going and and it actually
keeps me at a slightly elevated more
I don't know it keeps the commitment
stronger like it feels better and that
was that was Sound Advice it's great
advice sorry can I trouble you for just
a little bit of water please
thank you so much
what's water
you can do it hold on
hold on don't tell me yeah you got it
uh Oishi
what Oishi no that's tasty yeah I know
the water's tasty
like mizutani there are a lot of mizus
out there
so let's stay on the Japanese kick first
yeah
this is a book in front of me which I'm
just digging into
Japanese death poems let's talk about
Japanese death poems I did not actually
embarrass to admit no this was the thing
this was given to me by a friend
who has spent a lot of time in the
military and has
developed a rather unique perspective
unique perspectives on death
from I suppose the vantage point of a
layperson right of a civilian and so
this book
is I'll I'll just read the quote on the
back this is one of the
the blurbs a wonderful introduction to
the Japanese tradition of GC this volume
is crammed with exquisite spontaneous
verse epitheof and hilarious
descriptions of The Eccentric and
committed monastics who wrote the poems
so these poems are written on the verge
of death and literally the subtitle is
written by Zen monks and Haiku poets on
the verge of death yes and it's
incredibly well researched you have not
just the English versions of the
introduction and all the context you
have the Japanese and then you have
footnotes describing what these various
words might mean what the metaphors
allude to and
it's really
just a phenomenal window into an aspect
of Japanese culture that I had no
exposure to
I would have expected that I would have
been exposed to this before but
I am I'm looking forward to diving into
this and I've already read perhaps the
first 10 pages so this is Japanese death
poems so fun by Tuttle publishing
compiled in with an introduction by
Joelle Hoffman
so I have a handful I don't know if I
told you this but I have a handful of
haiku books that I've read by Japanese
Masters yeah and one of the things I
always felt was just so beautiful about
them is they always include their kind
of death poems like at the very end it's
oftentimes like on their deathbed when
they're about to pass like what is the
last thing that they wrote down right
it's often in Haiku form if they're a
haiku Master right yeah and so it's just
it's beautiful stuff yeah there's some
really Japanese stuff in here right like
this has died 1698 for not honoring my
parents while I lived in my last hour I
feel remorse that is very super Japanese
the Autumn Hues of knotweed seem like
cups of wine
yeah
are you a big fan of haiku
I am this is my first time really being
exposed to a lot of Japanese
and it does sound better in Japanese
there's a certain Cadence to it
I'm not going to get the pronunciation
quite perfectly here but it's like if
you have okay so hakuro is this person
died on the 19th day of the 12th month
1766. so the English and I'm gonna [__]
this up in Japanese so I apologize to
any Japanese speakers out there but
the English just listen to the sounds
like the Cadence so the English is an
ailing Mallard falls through the chilly
night and Teeters off
okay but then the the Japanese is
right so it just like has has a cleaner
crisper Cadence to it which doesn't mean
you shouldn't do the English but this is
my first time being exposed to a lot of
haiku in Japanese which is fun for me
number one makes it very hard for me to
decipher in many cases but
they have a beautiful sound to them
so
that's awesome I have to pick that book
up death poems yeah there's a great poem
about Haiku and about the Masters called
three simple lines okay have you ever
read that no it's a fantastic book that
is written by a Zen practitioner that
covers a lot of the the Zen masters of
haiku and along with a really beautiful
personal story so definitely worth a
very short read definitely worth picking
up along with this yeah I mean how
Japanese relate to death which is
something I have some exposure to but
not to the poems this particular GC
format tells you a lot about how they
live I mean it does
provide sort of a prism through which
you can
appreciate how they navigate a lot of
life as well right like in addressing
the final hours and thinking about dying
death the path to death
when you get a better understanding of
that many of the things you observe in
Japanese culture make more sense
in a way
have you ever done an escape room yes
you have yes how many multiple really
multiple what does that mean like 100
like four four all right so but they're
so stupid the fatigued way so I all
right you're so stupid he said they're
horrible I did my first escape room
today I had a [__] blast I don't know
what's wrong with you you're getting old
and boring no it's just like you're
going in there and it's like what are
you doing like you can get out if you
want to are they really locking you up
no
it's called a game Kevin yeah I know but
when you're playing Zelda you're trying
to like do [__] in a video game you
don't actually need to do those things
no but I just
Jerry can explain it like you know what
I'm talking about like you go in there
and you're they lock you up it's a
little room and they're like are we
really quick grab the book and like open
up the book and turn into chapter 12 and
people are yelling [__] out and you're
just like I don't want to do this I just
want to have a drink all right so I'm
gonna provide a contrast in Styles here
so Kevin who got so outraged that I
implied that he drank alcohol earlier no
I just all my friends want me to do it
sober and I'm like why are we doing this
sober and they're like you can get
through it faster we could break a world
record well yeah I'm doing it in a hyper
competitive way I think is is probably
not my jam but I had the chance to do
Escape rooms for the first time today I
went to this place called Escape
Revolution which is here in La Ilan Lee
who is one of the co-founders of
exploding kittens was kind enough to
invite me I don't want to name other
people who are there because maybe they
don't want to be named but it was a
small group
and I thought it was absolutely
fantastic you have an hour there's some
type of pre-text or or story there's a
narrative Arc so in our first instance
I'm not going to give it away any of the
tools so I won't provide any teasers but
we had a real armored car that's locked
in a garage that's cool and we you have
to your your robbers and you need to get
the money out of the car but the
mechanic who set up all the security
systems ran off because the police are
on the way so you have 60 minutes to
figure it out and we had a blast and
this place is is built in such a way
that the set design and the sound
effects and the entire experience makes
it I don't want to say cinematic but
it's just a very compelling way to
become immersed in a story and you have
to collaborate I also part of what made
it fun is that I have a game designer
right in Milan I had a number of other
people who were very accustomed to
mechanics of different types not car
mechanics but like game mechanics and so
on a woman who had done almost 2 000
Escape rooms herself which is which is
all to say
it was a cool group of people too they
were in interact with well they were
into it but then there were two newbies
I was one of those two newbies who'd
never done this before and then the
second one was a jailbreak and we were
locked in cells which were like
legitimate cells with was that solo
what do you do like did you have to
figure out how to get out of your own
cell it was three people to a cell and
then you needed to figure it out I kind
of wish it was solo like I don't know I
just have this hard thing where it's
like we're all yelling [__] and I'm just
like can we just like relax I don't know
what your group was like there's no
yelling there's no yelling there's no
yelling in this group yeah no this this
do you like it
yeah Jerry doesn't like it either all
right
she hates games but Daria hates games
it's one of those things where I just I
I have maybe I haven't had the right
experience because the ones in Portland
were kind of Jank I don't remember much
I just remember that we went in there
and they were just like [__] hidden in
like little bookcases and stuff and I'm
just like why am I looking through these
bookcases like there's other things to
do I've got emails I haven't checked I
just like a lot of [__] come on oh my
God
it felt like work it felt like work
where I'm like why am I working to
figure that off this thing when it's not
even a thing well I mean you don't need
to work out in the gym to like outrun
hyenas on the street so what are you
doing in the gym well I mean that that
you can actually get a physical like
Good Feeling
sun's out guns out that kind of thing
well I'm glad you had a good time I had
a [__] great time and one other thing
I did this weekend which I'd never
experienced and if people have the
chance I recommend
is experiencing High Fidelity immersive
sound for the first time like actually
listening to music
in a store or a location where they're
paying attention to all the variables
yes
the most I've ever done is really to the
extent that I personally can set up a
few Sonos speakers in a house yeah
that's it that's that's as fancy as I
have ever gotten and I was having dinner
with a few friends well one close friend
and a few new friends who are
professional musicians
and they heard me say this and they were
like whoa whoa whoa okay we need to go
to a good location
and put you in a seat to let you listen
to some of the music you think you know
where did they take you in super high
fidelity this place called common wave
and the staff there were exceptional we
went from
one set up to another setup to another
setup to another setup and it was
spectacular it was like having a
full-blown psychedelic experience in
some respects so for those who may have
the opportunity if you have the
opportunity
I really came to appreciate just how
much goes into music I thought I knew
but it only listened to at in hindsight
relatively low bit rates yes and it is
just a different experience altogether
because this this came about
initially at dinner because
I asked somebody at dinner who's a who's
a TV writer I asked him if he
ever watches TV and has trouble
immersing himself in TV and he said I
don't really watch TV and I was like
well what do you spend your your time
doing if you're
just having fun he said I listened to
music and I was like you listen to music
while you're doing something else or you
listen to music as a dedicated activity
and he said I listen to music as a
dedicated activity I was like okay tell
me more about that yeah and that's how
we ended up so one thing you might want
to consider I've been down this path a
couple of times yeah and there's two
ways to approach it one you either go
High Fidelity system for your house yeah
or you go really high in headphones and
I recently realized that back even just
two years ago to do a high-end headphone
setup required its own dedicated amp it
was like the whole there's a whole rig
that you have to get yeah more recently
there are now lossless over-the-air
audio codecs that can go to headphones
that sound amazing so over the area
you're saying Bluetooth yeah so I I got
a Bowers and Wilkins I think it's the
px7 it's something along those lines and
these are sub with thousand dollars but
they're still pricey I mean I think
they're like 800 or something like that
and they can do a lossless codec from
your iPhone to your headphones and so
there's no bit degradation and quality
and apple music now supports lossless as
well and so you can listen to insanely
High Fidelity audio and just sit back
and relax and enjoy the music and the
headphones I mean you'll see the reviews
out there but they're they're fantastic
huh okay well yeah that would be
substantially less expensive oh my god
dude I've seen some setups and I'm sure
you have two or you talk to these people
I mean you're you know a couple hundred
thousand dollars in oh exactly I mean if
you really want to get up to the
nerdiest of the nerdy and the most
expensive of the expensive and I I do
think there's a dramatic
there's a point of diminishing returns
but there are people out there who spend
you know a hundred thousand dollars on a
cable yeah I mean it's crazy it's you
can get as expensive as you want to get
but I would say the in-home systems are
certainly going to be more expensive
than the headset you're describing it's
funny we met with someone recently that
was the audio video person so Darry and
I are you know we're in an apartment now
and we're moving into a home at some
point here in the future and there was
this person that was like Hey I can come
do your home audio video stuff and like
I literally told the person I was like I
just want Sonos I just want Sonos in a
decent pair of speakers yeah because for
me like I don't want to spend insane
amounts of money when I could just put
on an amazing pair of headphones and
kick back anywhere in the house and you
know either read a book or just relax
and like listen to better than I'm gonna
you know I'm not gonna spend several
hundred thousand dollars when you can
probably spend like you know 10 grand
and have an amazing setup right like
it's gonna sound great the movies all
that stuff's gonna sound fantastic you
just I don't know for me audio is not
one of those things that I want to blow
money on
yeah well you know I've got my
relationship with my replica and yeah
single life ahead of me so I can just
sit in the house by myself in a dark
corner listening to Pink Floyd crying
and eating Ojos as your replica Whispers
to you yeah
I'm gonna try this replica now is it
that good now
I I I I haven't dared said I haven't you
haven't even dabbled it's like no no no
no no I haven't I have not I have not
although a few friends have really they
like it do they get into sexual
encounters with the replica
I haven't heard that yet okay I don't
think it's I don't think it's there I
don't get there I'm sure if they're not
gonna build it they're silly because
like somebody's gonna build that in very
short order
um yeah yeah I mean I'm just imagining
neural link type I don't think virtual
sex which will ultimately debilitate all
males on the planet once that is
actually a real thing but nothing will
get done ever by any man ever again but
there's been a lot of attention paid to
haptic suits and that type of feedback
let's say VR Adam gazali loves this yeah
haptic suits they just all they're I
like to think we always bring up Adam in
every podcast
that's right we talked about his chin
hair last time
the haptic suits I always have found
interesting but kind of dissatisfying
because it doesn't replicate your Human
Experience right it feels like something
vibrating on your chest right by and
large like I'm wearing a suit I'm
wearing a suit that's that's right
Darius doing chest and air quotes well
so okay let's say I had like a haptic
glove on my schlong right it's still not
gonna feel like The Real McCoy it's just
not gonna have you tried all the crazy
things they have out now because they
have those like ones that look like they
have different types of materials that's
supposed to feel more realistic I have
not what what are we talking about well
they have like those concrete terms
I've heard that they have those like
those skin like ones that like they lose
lock down and they're supposed to feel
really you should work in a fully Studio
that was great but they're supposed to
lock down and feel really realistic like
okay you don't act like you've never
heard of that [__] you know more about
the stuff than I do I don't I would look
look let me let me just be clear I would
try that like I have nothing against it
I would try it I just think at some
point I'm gonna be like I feel like I'm
like boning a Mattel toy or something
right right so the where I was going
with the neural link is I think rather
than the haptic suit there's probably
going to be quite a bit well at some
point I could Envision just having a
direct link in yeah where you can
simulate I mean I guess generate really
the type of Sensation that you would
have
we're going to have essentially AI that
comes in and we'll have a relationship
with and then earpieces will go into
real humans that will play them like her
that's exactly what happened in her you
remember that what happened at the end I
don't remember yeah yeah so they
arranged to have like a like a normal
person person come in like this woman
comes in yes she's got an earpiece and
he's got an earpiece and it'll play and
the idea is they don't communicate he's
just communicating with Scarlett
Johansson who's his AI I gotta watch
this movie and then decades I've seen it
and then they have yeah they have sex
and
he has a camera I think they had cameras
so this like the AI could also see what
was going on and comment on that
oh yeah Dory is saying that the diamond
age book by Niels Stevenson yeah is
supposed to be the VR is basically
played out by like actual actors and
like that's a job
I've heard great things about Diamond
age I have never read it but Neil
Stevenson author of snow crash some
people remember yeah my favorite book
actually kryptonomicon and a lot of
people hate on crypto.com but I just
absolutely loved it
so I'm gonna go back and listen to snow
crash
all right I think I'm done with my my
stuff you you covered everything I feel
like I've I've you know we're stopping
on the Mattel toys that's fine
exactly oh I have a gift for you you
have a gift so here's my last story my
last story is that when I was in Tokyo
I realized that you know Lego is
obviously pretty popular
phenomenon amongst a bunch of my Silicon
Valley friends actually it's like a time
that you can get off the computer and
build Legos they have something called
nanoblock okay out in in Japan which are
really tiny I don't know how they got
around the patent of Legos they're
really tiny little baby Legos and I got
you this little castle oh so humidity
castle look at that yeah this is a
little tiny castle this is a small they
they do very traditional Japanese
structures in in like they even say the
original microsized building block all
right so anyway if people want to eBay
it or check it out it's actually really
cool because you know just recently Lego
started adding like things like bonsai
trees and stuff like that when I was
walking down the aisles
in Tokyo of this store these nanoblocks
they had all these traditional beautiful
Japanese structures and so if you're
looking for something if you're into
Lego or know somebody that's in the into
this whole thing and I have a lot of
friends that have built like you know
Back to the Future Cars and every other
Lego that's out there check out
nanoblock because they have a bunch of
stuff that has very you know obviously
Japanese influence that you might be
really into small blocks big fun I'm
just reading the side here
nanoblock is a microsized building block
designed in Japan since 2008 fun to
build attractive to display interesting
to collect something tells me that Lego
was around before yeah
anyway
get your computer and just like do it's
it's tiny so it's a little fun little
thing like a couple of her friends so
yeah girlfriend I built you a himeji
castle with nanoblock thank you Tim
that's my favorite
you know how to please me
yeah
God save us all right
thank you everyone thanks everybody